these behind the scene clips are what's
known as
reference footage reference footage is
used in animation
all the time to make sure animated
characters movements like walking
and jumping are realistic probably the
most difficult scenes to animate
are fight scenes like the extremely
complex head to heads in
avatar the last airbender and the legend
of korra
instead of just going on the ground on
his butt he actually drops down and he's
like
like on his finger there's like air you
know there's like way there there we go
to animate them meant finding someone
who could perform and choreograph
multiple martial arts styles
it was fun i was the only person on the
planet with my job for a hot minute
that's sifu kisu a master of martial
arts and the fight choreographer and
reference actor for avatar the last
airbender
kisu has over 40 years of experience in
martial arts and has studied taekwondo
karate jujitsu northern shaolin style
kung fu
and more kisu worked on all 61 episodes
of avatar and collaborated with a team
of martial arts experts on quora
in avatar having a choreographer and
reference actor was especially important
because the four kingdoms used different
fighting styles with their own specific
movements
kisu based each distinct bending style
on a different martial art the fluid
movements of water bending are based on
tai chi
the spinning movements of air bending
are taken from bagua
the powerful movements of fire bending
are based on northern shaolin style kung
fu
and the sturdy low center of gravity
movements of earth bending
are based on hungar the first step in
creating these animated fight sequences
is storyboarding
when the artists receive a script and
draw rough sketches of an entire episode
the descriptions of fight scenes and
scripts typically only include the broad
strokes of the fight
so the director of the episode will
often create the temporary choreography
during this initial phase
when we got to the actual fighting you
know who kicks who punches
who's the aggressor and all that often
times i do something like this where
it's like aim
shoots air and i'll just do this or
something
do a drawing that looks like that after
storyboarding comes choreography
where kisu met with the animation team
to refine the choreography of the fight
scenes
there were usually about five to ten
fight scenes per episode that had to be
choreographed
kyusu says that in this first meeting he
would just pitch a series of movements
that he thought would represent a
certain type of vending
for example kisu said that if a fire
bending technique called for swinging
flaming fists
he would suggest an appropriate movement
such as striking motions from double
dagger form kung fu
other animated shows have tried to mix
magic and martial arts
but kisu noted that they don't often use
martial arts movements when conjuring
magic
you can see this when comparing avatar
the last airbender to other shows
featuring supernatural powers like some
scenes from dragon ball z
it's like if my if i'm holding a stone
in my hand like this and it jumps out of
my hand and hits the camera
you're going to question that right but
if i wind up and i make the motion in
the antique of throwing that
then that's going to read more to
something you can understand right we
thought that that would be important
that it it should come from somewhere
to go to somewhere and i think that was
one of the big contributing factors
to the success of avatar the last
airbender
after kisu and the director agreed on
the choreography they filmed the action
kisu sometimes performed the fight
choreography for two or more
fighting characters separately animators
would later take these shots and combine
them into a single fight between
characters
after filming the artist took the
footage and used it to add more detail
like specific poses to their initial
storyboards the time it cost to do the
reference filming was recouped by having
an extremely accurate model for drawing
ultimately this led to a better final
product because the character poses were
more accurate
the storyboard team sent the polish
storyboards back to kisu for review
then it'd be sort of a back and forth
where like maybe
we'd come up with a new shot that that
we never talked about during the first
meeting this process was repeated two to
three times until everyone was satisfied
with the result
before sending the finished storyboards
off to a team in korea for the final
animation the director would film one
final version of the fight with kisu
with all of the finalized camera angles
it was gonna be a wide angle we had
these bleachers
in like a little makeshift basketball
court at nickelodeon and guys would
crawl up there with the camera and get
it you know get a down shot
we'd change to a wide angle and make it
look like it was really far away
like the fight with zuko and azula on
the boat dock where she
tried to scratch his face and they were
at a fire battle that was done on the
front steps at nickelodeon in front of
the
spongebob statue storyboards aren't
created for every frame
they're created for every third frame of
animation so the reference footage made
it easier for the animators to create
the in-between frames that were missing
while having reference footage is ideal
sometimes it was impossible to capture
accurate live-action reference footage
mostly because the characters possess
magical powers some fights in the show
called for a movement that no real human
could replicate
like this scene from cora in these
situations the martial artists would
split up the action into several chunks
which would be stitched together in the
final animation
in the beginning credits for avatar last
year when zuko would do the
the big whirlwind kick with the flaming
come down and hit the ground
at the time i was recovering from an
injury and so i couldn't do that kick
that's
we call it a one-legged whirlwind kick
and so i
literally rolled over someone's back
like someone bent over and then i
just rolled over that person's back the
opening credits for cora they show the
the airbender does this crazy thing
where he he kicks this way
and lays back that way i ended up just
holding brian in my arms
which is really funny it's this
life-like martial arts choreography and
attention to detail
that make the difference between static
fight scenes like this
and dynamic ones like this
[Music]